NFL film series all or nothing featuring
the Cardinals Arizona Cardinals
available on Amazon that starts July 1st
the 8 episode series follows the
Cardinals throughout the entire 2015
season one of their stars Patrick
Peterson defensive back joining us in
studio what was the easiest part to let
them see in the toughest part to let
this film crew see the easiest part was
definitely practice the toughest part
was probably letting the cameras come
home on with you and let them you know
let the audience the world see what we
do and so this you and your wife you
know and what are they sitting like
conversations conversations me getting
the baby room the nursery ready for the
baby then did you do the remodeling no I
did the wife did the remodeling but most
of the picking out a new hassle because
I was in midseason so I didn't have time
to do all that stuff so I got a pass but
um you know us being in the going
through the pregnancy the pregnancy you
know going through the labor that was
pretty cool then when she got here going
through going to her first game it's
pretty cool wait so the cameras were
there in the delivery booth no it wasn't
there in the delivery room but I gave
them some footage from Maya for my phone
oh you took footage yeah that's pretty
intense though yeah but is there's
nothing too crazy
there's no okay there's nothing over the
top but did people try to prepare you
for the birth of your daughter
like this is what's gonna happen or cuz
I tried to tell people once you're in
that emergency room
mm-hmm and all of a sudden it like stuff
starts happening yeah and then you just
see there were doctors coming in and
doors that opened up and I didn't know
there were doors and next thing you know
like there's a baby in your arms yeah it
was it it all happens so quickly but no
one prepared me for that moment but um
did you cry I didn't well I did cry I
said one tear once she first wants the
doctor put her out and I first saw
because obviously you know you've been
waiting
launched to see what she looked like and
and obviously to have your first kid is
it's definitely a joy but I did shed one
tear but it
there was nothing like once they started
giving her like the the the pain meds
yeah and all that stuff it then that's
when the intensity definitely picks up a
lot
once that uh once that part starts to
happen now your daughter his name is
Peyton
yup Peyton and and that is Peyton
Manning yeah my wife Peyton Manning is
from blue New Orleans and my wife is
from New Orleans and my wife loves
Peyton Manning as a quarterback you know
waitwait house just go over as a
defensive back that she loves hate the
Manning well she's been a Peyton Manning
fan for quite a while so that's the only
pass that I give her you know she says I
want a name I want to name our baby
after Peyton Manning your response was I
was I was actually okay with it uh it
started with a P and in an spelled
different it's spelled in a very very
unique way and I thought it was pretty
cool was PA ity n so I thought that was
pretty cool and and Peyton is just
something that I did that stuck with me
what if she said I want to name the baby
after Cam Newton after the playoff loss
if she had said I was like you gotta be
kidding
he's Patrick Peterson of the Cardinals
joining us the series on Amazon starts
July 1st it's all or nothing featuring
the Arizona Cardinals it's an
eight-episode series but have you looked
at that playoff loss to Carolina I did
how tough it was very tough but you know
watching that game it was Parsifal for
us to get back into it but you know I
just thought that we dug ourselves in
such a deep and such deep of a hole that
we couldn't we couldn't get back and
those guys did a great job of keeping
the momentum and making sure that we
didn't do anything to to get anything
going but it was very very tough loss
we're definitely looking forward to
getting past it during this season and
hopefully we can take the next step
if I said you could face Cam Newton or
Russell Wilson who would you rather face
I mean both of those guys are tough you
know cuz you know Russell does a great
job of creating that second chance with
his feet Forrest's not running I mean he
runs when he can I won't know when he
wants to but he's looking to pass
first and foremost and Cam Newton this
guy that can wear and tell you tell you
your defense down with his power so
Russell Wilson is much more finessing
and Camp Cam Newton is a much powerful
powerful much quarterback but I'd rather
not face neither one of them because
it's tough to face a dual quarterback
but but who frustrates you more out of
that Russell he does far as far as a
secondary Russell yes he's in the pocket
for four four seconds the next thing you
know you're on to one sidelined in the
next sideline he has the ball in his
hands for you know 15 plus seconds and
as a DB that's tough you can eventually
catch cam right Russell was a little
more elusive yeah he's very very
dangerous when when he's back there
playing that backyard football who talks
to you
does anybody talk trash quarterback wise
no no quarterback says anything like
Brady sometimes we get into a defensive
players faces I never I never got into
it with on with a quarterback but
receivers all-time who's first and
foremost they're on the list think
receivers you're gonna have a
conversation
my first game was Steve Smith you know
and I had a very very long game which
Steve Smith running his mouth at me and
he had a big game so only good thing
about it we end up winning that game and
I had the last laugh with the 89 yard
punt return oh what a touchdown but uh
Steve Smith did you say anything to
Steve I didn't because Larry me being a
rookie this is my first start first game
except to me 11 I believe 9/11 at the
time so Larry's telling you all week and
Patrick you have to be quiet don't say
anything Larry Fitzgerald yeah he's
going just be cool don't don't say
anything I'm going you know he's a
little Tasmanian devil just let him be
I let him be and he slowly started to
get under my skin and I didn't let him
get there but um it was a fun game it
was definitely one of the games to
remember but do you want to be engaged
with somebody like do you get better if
somebody is giving you talking talk in
my opinion I do because you know when I
was in high school I saw guys did
because you know with me been a bit shot
you know everybody's taking their shots
at me so it was always um they always
added fuel to the fire to me want
someone always jabbing at me poking at
me trying to get under my skin and just
always found a way to make me better but
you understand the Odell Beckham and
Josh Norman like it could escalate to
something like that I would never let it
escalate to anything like that because I
respect the game you know I believe you
know that was kind of out of hand
it was out of here all right I mean I
got to be dangerous yeah that's what I'm
saying so I you know I definitely
wouldn't let it get that far because I
like I say I definitely respect the show
far too much and definitely would have
been a national televised game so don't
nationally-televised changed everything
no not really but you know like I said I
definitely respect the game and you know
by being nationally televised you know
it was just more small audience watching
it live you know who do you not want to
see lined up next the opposite you
receiver yeah I took him all along but
is there one that you just say man I got
a long day ahead Tony O'Brien man I'm
Antonio Brown you know it's just so
quick and the thing that that it treats
me the most about Antonio that you know
does a great job of changing his aiming
point up far as the defensive back you
know by my aiming point being you know
the Peck to the armpit you know he does
a great job of hiding that at time what
do you mean heck to the armpit um you
know this is my a me point up here so by
your heart is a little bit above that
exactly that's his aiming point that's
my a me point for where all your gonna
hit here what I want to hit him up horse
when I'm up and my press technique you
know he does a great job of hiding that
and another thing that he does really
really good at he's always running and
then he's never stopped like he's always
running in and out of
and he does a great job was trying to
wear and tear too deep as a back down so
he can have that's alluring and going
against him this year and that's how I
can see why he have those big game so
late in games because you know he does a
great job of his conditioning and he
does a great job of wearing the the
defensive back down he's a tough kid he
is he's very tough that took that hit
that he took in Cincinnati like I didn't
realize it at the time that he got you
know clipped pretty good I mean he got
banged up yeah Dennis hit the turf you
got banged up pretty well the NFL Films
series all or nothing featuring the
Cardinals is available on Amazon
starting July 1st
it's a 8 episode series it follows the
Cardinals throughout the entire 2015
season so unlike Hard Knocks
Mart Knox does preseason all right this
was regular season for you hmm
was it weird though to see cameras like
all the time did you behave differently
when you see the cameras you know in the
beginning stage it was kind of weird you
know seeing cameras there every day you
know all day because you know that's
something we definitely wasn't
accustomed to but as time you know
passed on the cameras started to grow on
us you know the cameras thing almost
seemed like furniture to us that we
didn't mind it
we almost forgot that the cameras was
there so we didn't behave you different
you know you know we did we still said
some of the things that we wanted to say
coaches still got on us the way they
needed to so it definitely is definitely
it's definitely good pg-13 for sure
now I notice here on the man cave you
looked at the Larry Bird picture over
your shoulder with Robert Parish Sheriff
Kevin McHale and I said are you a
basketball fan you said big basketball
fan but you're a Kobe fan I am
and so Kobe was your Michael Jordan
mm-hmm
did you ever meet Kobe um I haven't I
haven't met Kobe but I had opportunity
to meet and play golf with Michael
Jordan a couple times how was that
awesome they did trash talk I was on
Michael I was on his team oh okay sure
lucky I was lucky I was very looking he
was definitely giving it to Dwight
Freeney and
who was a king GOG ken ken griffey jr.
he's not afraid to give it to anybody no
not at all not at all my but my favorite
moment in Michael Jordan there was a
90-foot putt kids you're not in the
rough first cut and he said before you
hit the place I only two people in the
world can make this play and he said me
and Tiger Woods and I kid you not drink
only MJ write what it was it about Kobe
though that you like uh he reminded me
so much of Michael Jordan you know off
the clips that I watched because I was
never able to you know I didn't have a
chance to watch Michael play because I
mean I'm fairly young I was born in the
90s for ninety to be exact and watching
the clips and watching Kobe Bryant
played reminded me so much of him and
the the tenacity that he played the
anger they played so you're eight years
old and you fall in love with the Lakers
yeah I was like that guy that he's my
favorite basketball player could you
imagine Kobe as a football player I can
I can't he will be like a tyrant
Matthew's like the Wiz his attitude yeah
but Kobe's six six that's why I was
gonna say this height it's a little
different if he was a little shorter
maybe like six two ish I could see him
playing you know maybe corner you're
special in his day and age you need a
big big coin he'd want to be a wide
receiver probably so but he's the guy
who needs the ball could you could you
build a good football team from
basketball players or two too tall yeah
I think those guys leverage is so
important right I think those guys are
just way too big like Shaq yeah I don't
see it Shaq couldn't play nose tackle
maybe he possibly could but I just don't
see how that I see Shaq as a tackle yeah
I see basketball players you know
officer lon how about LeBron
LeBron could possibly be a tight end but
I saw some saw some video of I believe
there was playing the Raptors and
they're throwing the ball around in the
arena he was dropping around I don't
know if he was joking around but he
wasn't catching those ball he was
a wide receiver yeah yeah Highschool
long time yep
please great athlete Oh hell of an
athlete but all it takes is one hit just
what I'm saying you find out what I'm
saying that's the moment of reality when
you hit them and then all of a sudden
they go oh my real hits with 17 weeks
straight right yeah
could you could you take that you ever
heard somebody cry when you hit them no
you ever see like groans or mono cuz you
always see like after the fab Oh like
when you're in a moment like everything
just go completely quiet like I don't
hear anything
is that the best kind of hit when you'd
like it it's so smooth like it doesn't
feel anything
whoa I'm always in that moment like once
like the quarterback says hi I don't
hear nothing like anything until like
maybe the ball is coming to me or right
right after then that's when I kind of
tune back into you know what's going on
in the crowd and on the field that's the
same when you're back with a punt return
mm-hmm and you get to see the whole
field there you get to create whatever
you want to create mm-hmm how much free
what's that feeling like when that ball
is in the air and you're not quite sure
where you're going but you gotta you got
to make a decision really quickly uh-huh
you know that's the better part return
to me it's so much fun because being a
difference back you know you know we
barely get opportunity to get our hands
on balls unless you're getting
challenged you know 15 you know 20 times
game but when you get opportunity to get
back there and fill the punt it's
nothing like because like you say you
have unless you get a great punter and
like the guy with the with the Rams who
can put you in tight spots but when you
back then you you get an opportunity to
fill that ball and run two spots worse
where it's unpredictable you kind of
fill it into that intent into those
spots on the field
have you ever been tackled by a punter I
have oh man
the actually it was the one to break the
NFL record
against the Seattle Seahawks there's
gonna be four the fifth they said Ryan
is that his name
yeah for the fifth part return the break
to NFL record and I got tripped up by
the part that's not him I missed that
toggle play he didn't even he didn't
even talk to me he literally with me on
my thigh and I felt how soft are you
that I was already going down if I was
already going down and he got me in man
that was you were gonna score another
touchdown that would have been for the
record man I'd have been all along at
the top I think it's four of us with
four touchdowns so what does Deion
Sanders still mean two defensive backs
now because I it feels like that memory
of Deion still is the most important
player at that position that we've ever
had that's like Michael Jordan you know
when you talk to Kobe you know who he
wanted to be like you know to talk to
you know Russell Wilson LeBron James who
they wanted to be like Michael Jordan
and that side is in this and football
this was as the deeper back who do you
want to be like who do you want to
emulate your game up Deion Sanders
because he was the guy that transcended
the game into a whole nother perspective
you know no you know you had to know the
Willie Brown you know the Darryl greens
its Revis in that conversation no
question you know of course I believe
Revis definitely got it back to where it
needed to be you know having the seasons
that he had because you know you had to
D'Angelo Ross but you didn't they wasn't
doing some of the things what the
referee was doing like taking guys
completely yeah out of the game but some
of the things where Deion Sanders was
able to do to they take interceptions
persist to come back and get on offense
the next thing they'll go back on punt
return and kick return the guy
definitely did something different
that's why I want to the word a number
21 and do some of the things he did as
well and I like that NFL Films series
all or nothing featuring the Arizona
Cardinals available on Amazon starting
July 1st the 8 episode series follows
the Cardinals throughout the entire 20
teen season including the birth of
Peyton Petersen yep always great to see
a patrick thanks for joining us the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience